listen I just need to say one thing here
at the top I am really sick and tired of
people hating on cargo shorts
every year around this time as the
weather gets warmer you know that's why
I'm thinking about it now it's getting
warmer out and but what do you see you
see people online who are mocking cargo
shorts and the men who wear them and say
oh you better not be wearing cargo
shorts but I think this mockery is
unfair and and bigoted and hypocritical
as well especially coming from women
which is usually where it comes words
usually women who are complaining about
cargo shorts well let's think about this
for a second ladies okay what happens
when you go out with your husband or
your boyfriend right you you don't feel
like carrying a purse around and you
don't have pockets in your skirt or
dress or whatever so suddenly he becomes
like your pack mule who has to carry
around your your your your phone and
your ID and whatever other paraphernalia
you feel like having with you but yet if
he decides that he wants to wear a pair
of cargo shorts with extra pockets to
accommodate the the additional baggage
suddenly he's a nerd no see that's just
that's just wrong
hey let me tell you something else if he
wants to wear a fanny pack that is
perfectly acceptable - that's totally
fine that is practical and stylish in
fact I'll say this
a man in cargo shorts a fanny pack and
velcro shoes is a man who knows how to
combine utility and fashion that's a
keeper right there ladies you see a man
like that you know that's a keeper
that's the minutes that that's the kind
of guy you want your life all right
that's all I'm gonna say I just felt the
need I need as a as an avid cargo shorts
fan myself I felt the need to say that
okay there's a ton of big news happening
and I started my show on a Monday
talking about cargo shorts instead
that's what separates me really from
every other show is basically my
irrelevance is what separates me from
the other ones I do want to talk about
Ilhan Omar and Tiger Woods and all that
stuff but first let's check in with
light stream you know what feels great
besides wearing cargo shorts
on a hot day paying off high interest
credit cards also getting a lower rate
and saving money all those three things
at once feels really good it's like a
load off your shoulders right it's it is
well it's it's much like when when when
someone is carrying something in their
cargo shorts for you it's it's a load
off it's you're taking that load off and
putting in someone else's cargo shorts
so and you can really feel that weight
being lifted here here's the good news
you can refinance your credit card
balances and also save with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream you can get a fixed rate as low
as six point one far four percent APR
with Auto pay and you can get a loan
from $5,000 to $10,000 and there are no
fees and you can even get your money as
soon as the day you apply so this is a
win-win-win situation as far as I'm
concerned if you want to save you more
my listeners get an additional interest
rate discount the only way to get this
discount pay attention you have to go to
light stream dot-com slash Walsh right
now
okay that's Li gh t STR II AM dot-com
slash Walsh go there right now and you
get the additional interest rate
discount but you got to make sure you
put in that slash walls part there too
as well so subject to credit approval
rate includes 0.5% auto pay discount
terms and conditions apply and offers
are subject to change without notice
visit light stream comm slash Walsh for
more information okay as far as Tiger
Woods go I was I was legitimately
excited to see the Tiger Woods won the
Masters yesterday as you no doubt heard
I don't watch golf I don't really care
about golf the only professional golfer
I can name is Tiger Woods but I will say
that I was I was happy to hear about his
victory and I was happier about
something else which is that you know
turning on the news going online
whatever it seems like almost everybody
is happy right that he won yeah there
are a few naysayers here and there I'm
sure but most everyone is happy about it
and I thought as I was watching this
reaction I thought well this is
this is good because this is a positive
thing that we all still seem to share as
Americans is that we all love stories of
redemption right we love underdog
stories we love comeback stories stories
of redemption now I've said in the past
that one of the problems in America is
that I'm not sure I can think of one
positive uniting sort of principle or
value or trait that we all share and if
you want to have a real country you need
to have--you things that you all share
besides the fact that you all happen to
live on the same plot of land there
needs to be something deeper than that
and and I still think that there aren't
many uniting characteristics that we all
have as Americans anymore unfortunately
but this might be one maybe this might
be the only one is that we all love a
good comeback story and that's pretty
good that's I mean that's not enough to
build a country around or maintain a
country around but it is a good thing so
at least we have that and and let's hang
on to it so congratulations to Tiger
Woods here's something that isn't so
great though
Ilhan Omar let's let's go back and
review here for a moment to get
ourselves caught up to speed with
everything going on with this so
representative of Omar as you probably
heard was was speaking at a care banquet
that CAIR the Muslim group care I'm
speaking at a care banquet few weeks ago
and during those remarks that's when she
said infamously now this because they
recognize that some people did something
and that all of us were starting to lose
access to our civil liberties now of
course everyone is focused on the the
part where she says some people did
something because of how flippantly it
dismisses 9/11 but she also said in that
same clip she also lies about America
and says that Muslims are losing
access to their civil liberties because
of 9/11 now where is that happening she
doesn't she doesn't provide any examples
of it this is by far not the only time
not the first time I've heard this claim
that Muslims lost their civil liberties
in America after 9/11 but how so where
did that happen now you could certainly
argue that all Americans lost some of
their civil liberties after 9/11
what would the Patriot Act and the TSA
and so on and I would agree with that
claim but to say that Muslims were
somehow legally singled out is just
simply false it's just a lie but that
aside the thing that most people have
hummed in on is the part where she says
you know some people did something and
for good reason especially considering
her history of this kind of thing here
she is not long ago laughing about
al-qaeda watch this when I was in
college I took a terrorism class and was
interesting in the class with every time
the the professor said al-qaeda he sort
of like his shoulders went up and it was
you know you know but but but it is it
is that you don't say America with an
intensity
you don't say England with intensity you
don't say the army with but you say
these these names because you you want
that that word to carry weight you want
it to leave something it has no meaning
now the left of course has gone into
over try overdrive trying to defend
well not will deflect really not not
defend because there's nothing you could
say to defend it so instead they're just
deflecting which is what they always do
with with these sorts of things so
they've been trying to deflect in two
ways number one they've been saying that
the some people did something remarks
were taken out of context and number two
they've been saying that we her critics
by criticizing her are putting her life
in danger so we should just stop doing
that because we are we are inciting
violence against her let's take a look
at both of the both of these but we'll
do it one at a time here
first of all it really appears to me
that most people in this country don't
know what the phrase out of context
means it seems that most people when
they say that when they say that oh that
was out of context what they really mean
to say is that in their opinion the
offending remarks weren't really that
offensive which may or may not be the
case but whether or not it is the case
that's not what out of context means out
of context is when just a portion of
someone's comments are shown in order to
convey a meaning that is actually the
opposite of or at least totally
different from their actual apparent
meaning and one way of doing that is to
show the clumsily worded portion but
then not some other portion of the same
remarks where they sort of clarify and
flesh out their idea more to frame it a
little bit more appropriately now and
that kind of thing happens all the time
that's what out of context is it's when
you win it always starts with someone
who has the whole the whole picture and
they purposefully take this one little
part that that you know paints the
entire situation you know in a different
light perfect example of this there are
so many examples we could we could look
at perfect example would be the
Covington Catholic kids that is an
example of taking something out of
context where you have that one little
snippet
that at first that only showed the you
know the one kid and the rest of his
friends kind of staring at and you know
sort of look like he was in the face of
this Native American smiling at him and
that's out of context because then once
you saw the entire context it completely
flipped the the situation on its head
and you saw that oh no actually the
Native American guy Nathan Phillips he
was the one who instigated this he was
okay so that's that's what out of
context is Omar's comments were not out
of context and to show you that let's go
to the Washington Post's video the post
is of course running damage control for
a member of their own party which it's a
Democrat parties their party they are
that they are a a member of the sort of
PR the unofficial PR firm for the
Democrat Party they released a
fact-checking a quote-unquote
fact-checking video which supposedly
shows the full context of Omar's
comments and and in in it's supposed to
show that well really it's not as bad as
it looked this this video is supposed to
debunk the controversy and vindicate
Ilhan Omar so let's take a look now
again this is the Washington Post
they're trying to run cover for they're
doing the best they can and so this is
the Washington Post putting those
comments in context watch
far too long we have lived with the
discomfort of being a second-class
citizen and frankly I'm tired of it and
every single Muslim in this country
should be tired of it here was founded
after 9/11 because they recognized that
some people did something and that all
of us were starting to lose access to
our civil liberties so you can't just
say that today someone is looking at me
strange that I am going to try to make
myself look Pleasant you have to say
this person is looking at me strange I
am not comfortable with it I am going to
go talk to them and ask them why because
that is the right you have okay does
that change anything at all so that's
the full context does it how does that
affect what she what she's in trouble
for saying if anything it makes it worse
because the rest of the context is her
just painting Muslims as the real
victims of 9/11 that that's the full
context the full context is she's the
victim and Muslims are the victims so I
don't see how that helps her case at all
she says some people did something and
then she goes on to talk about the poor
Muslims she doesn't make any additional
comments about 9/11 that would shed a
better light on the some people did
something remarks okay she doesn't do
that so this is not taken out of context
now you may be confused and you may ask
well what does the Washington Post even
think that this video proves why would
they
what's the pointer the the the
fact-checking and they're not adding
anything to it at all
what's their point well the answer is
that it there they don't really they
know that the video doesn't prove
anything the point of the video is to
not be watched the video exists just so
that a debunking video
exists so that most people will see it
and say oh the Washington Post already
debunked that and not actually watch the
video itself and and that's and that's
true that's what that that's what will
happen with most people there was the
same thing you remember what the Planned
Parenthood undercover videos where they
Planned Parenthood officials were caught
saying all kinds of horrible things
start trying to sell aborted baby parts
and there were all kinds of articles
that were written in the mainstream
media and videos done debunking the
controversy and so on but if you
actually read those articles or watch
the videos you saw that oh they didn't
really debunk anything they didn't even
try because there's there's they can't
the Planned Parenthood was caught
red-handed trying to sell aborted baby
parts is right there on video but the
mainstream media knew that most people
aren't what most people most people they
just want to see that there are articles
out there debunking this they're not
going to read it they're not going to
take the time to read it they just want
to know that it's there so that they can
say oh that was the bunk but it gets
worse as the video the debunking video
goes on it gets much worse watch this
Plus not everyone always refers to the
9/11 terrorists as terrace
[Music]
and the people who knocked these
buildings down will hear all of us
[Music]
okay all right now
Omar herself made this same comparison a
few days ago as well so the post and
Omar are working from the same talking
point she cheat here but that comparison
is obviously completely absurd and I
don't think I need to explain why but I
will anyway George Bush was standing on
the rubble of the tower impromptu
talking into a bullhorn and he was
threatening to find and kill the people
who did it okay so nobody thinks with
with with President Bush which by the
way that's I think that moment right
there is one of the great moments in
presidential histories it's one of the
great moments any president has ever had
in my opinion so say whatever else you
want about Bush and there are plenty of
things you can criticize about him but
that was just a an all-time great
historic moment by a president and I
think a moment that most presidents that
we've ever had would just wouldn't have
been able wouldn't wouldn't have done
that anyway he's standing on the rubble
of the tower pointing to it and saying
the people who did this I mean work he
didn't say it explicitly but what he's
saying is the people who did this we're
gonna kill him nobody in their right
mind thinks that he was dismissing or
downplaying 9/11 you don't stand on the
rubble of the destroyed tower saying
we're gonna kill the people who did this
because you want to downplay 9/11 that
comparison is I mean it's so
unbelievably dishonest but again as far
as the Washington Post is concerned you
know that that little part of the video
is about four minutes in they know that
most people aren't going to see that
that's just filler so from there
congressman Dan Crenshaw and many other
conservatives have criticized Omar and
rightfully so
and then a couple of days ago Trump sent
out this video via tweet he was founded
after 9/11
because they recognize that some people
did something
you have no idea rather I'd have another
one another plane just hit some people
did something oh my goodness there is
smoke burn like the Pentagon some people
did something it just blew straight into
it
[Music]
and things just went nuclear from there
right on the part of the Democrats
they're now crying that Omar's life is
being jeopardized by the criticisms
against her and that Trump and other
Republicans are inciting violence in
fact all the Democrats especially all
the 20/20 Democrats the ones running for
president 2020 basically in unison
started using the exact same language
incitement to violence but they all they
all latched on to the same term almost
as if it was coordinated who knew they
all latched on to that same term at the
exact same time and they just started
saying it and repeating it over and over
and over again
Omar is is the real victim right
criticizing her as incitement now Ilhan
Omar put out a statement last night
hammering on this theme she says since
the president's tweet Friday evening I
have experienced an increase in direct
threats on my life many directly
referencing or replying to the
president's video I think the Capitol
Police the FBI the house sergeant of
arms and the Speaker of the House for
their attention to these threats violent
crimes and other acts of hate by
right-wing extremists and white
nationalists are on the rise in this
country and around the world we could no
longer ignore that they are being
encouraged by the occupant of the
highest office in the land
counties that hosted a 2016 Trump rally
saw 226 percent increase in hate crimes
in the months following the rally and
assaults insults increase when cities
host Trump rallies this is particularly
concerned and given the president's
visit to my home state of Minnesota on
Monday violent rhetoric and all forms of
hate speech have no place blah blah blah
blah blah
of course the the Terp the figure she's
using there two hundred twenty six
percent increase you can't take any of
that at face value I hope that of course
you would know that but yeah violent
crime from white nationalists is on the
rise around the world
yeah well does it come anywhere close to
Islamic terrorism no not anywhere close
to that but of course
Ilhan Omar she's worried about the what
she's worried about white nationalist
violence around the world
not so much about Islamic terrorism just
she doesn't really talk much about that
except to laugh about it and okay let's
clarify a few things here number one if
if we're inciting violence against Ilhan
Omar by quoting her and accusing her of
being flippant and dismissive of 9/11
which she was then is she not inciting
violence against the president when she
claims that he's encouraging violence I
mean doesn't this go both ways and in
any case criticism is not incitement do
you know what in citement is incitement
is when you get up and actively and
explicitly encourage people to commit
violence that's incitement and that's
illegal but nobody is doing that in in
reference to Omar at least not any
prominent person is doing that what
conservatives are doing is we're just
we're criticizing her which we have
every right to do and which we are
completely not just legally permitted
but we are morally justified in doing so
because what she said in the kind the
kinds of thing that she always says are
abhorrent
if criticism is incitement then I've
been the victim of incitement thousands
of times and if criticism is incitement
then President Trump has been the victim
of incitement hundreds of millions of
times but it is interesting though isn't
it how Ilhan Omar and AOC and the other
women in that contingent usually claim
to be strong independent women but the
moment you criticize them they fall into
a lump on the floor and become these
damsels in distress don't they and
something else is interesting that
leftists have spent two years claiming
that the President of the United States
is a secret Russian agent in league with
Putin claiming that Brett Kavanaugh is a
is a serial gang rapist
they've they've accused a bunch of
random high-school students of being
racist bigots because they looked at a
Native America
man yet now after all of that they're
worried about incitement they're worried
about irresponsible rhetoric after all
of that yeah I don't I don't buy that
for a second not for a second
and when it when a liberal fired 70
rounds into a GOP baseball game a couple
of years ago did any of these Democrats
say anything about incitement and
rhetoric did any of them all the ones
that are so worried about it now did
they have anything to say about that no
not a single one because they are
conniving frauds in the Democrat Party
almost without exception okay what else
well a lot of people have sent me this
study that was done allegedly proving
that men with facial hair carry around
more germs than dogs and they don't have
much to say about this is if you see
this study it is vicious dishonest anti
beard propaganda and the scientists
behind it are all a bunch of beardless
baby faces who are jealous that they can
only grow patchy peach fuzz okay all
anti beard rhetoric at the end of the
day originates from envious beardless
people be they men or women and and
that's all I'll say about that so you
just you just toss that toss that to the
side one other thing I wanted to mention
before getting into some emails I don't
mean to open up this can of worms again
but I also can't resist so a few days
ago I said on Twitter half joking that
dogs are the most overrated things in
the universe second perhaps only to the
to the the original Star Wars trilogy
and now I do think that dogs and Star
Wars are overrated but obviously I'm
engaging in a bit of in a bit of joking
hyperbole at the same time and and but
but from there as you might expect the
dog people started coming and
they claiming that you know dogs are
wonderful they're the most loving
creatures in the world and so much more
loving than people and so on and I
simply and calmly explained that dogs
are you know dogs are fine but actually
dogs aren't really capable of love in
the human sense because they don't have
that same awareness of themselves they
don't have the same ability to choose
you know that they're largely
instinctive animals and love requires an
awareness of the south it also requires
an ability to choose which so animals
just don't have that and and their love
for you is based mostly on the fact that
you feed them if they were starving and
you were incapacitated or dead they
would just eat you so and that's fine
right there they're dogs it's okay dogs
are dogs no big deal but if you really
think that dogs are more capable of love
than humans I think that says a lot more
about you than it does about dogs or
other people it just means that you're a
bit of a sociopath if you actually have
people in your life who you really love
like children spouse you would never
equate a dog's affection for its
caretakers to human love and that's all
I said
right the basic point an obvious point
no big deal well as expected since then
I've gotten some very angry messages
from dog lovers including this one which
I just I have to read because it's so
over the top
I have thanks now remember again keep in
mind why this message was sent because I
just I just said that about dogs you
know dogs are fine but they're they're
not people that was basically my point
okay
I never advocated that we go and kill
all the dogs in the world or whatever I
never said that but here's the message
from someone says you hating dogs so
much makes you a worthless quote-unquote
human being go after yourself because
God knows that's the only way you get
any unless you're white unless you get
your poor wife drunk I feel especially
sorry for your kids who have a POS like
you as
father the fact that you reproduced and
the fact that you exist is sickening now
again that was because I said that dogs
are overrated the person who sent that
message by the way is a middle-aged
woman looks to be just kind of like a
normal soccer mom based on her picture
and I'm sure that if you bumped into
this person on the street you'd think
that this is just a normal person right
but behind the scenes she's sending
delusional sexually charged screens to
people on Twitter who don't like dogs
enough and that's one thing I find
interesting about what I do for a living
because I get a lot of emails and
messages every single day and I think
that they really you know they really
give you an insight into what people are
really like more so than interacting
with people in the real world you know
bumping into a stranger and exchanging
pleasantries with them doesn't really
give you any sense of what a person's
actually like because because even even
a even of serial killer could you know
he's capable of making small talk on an
elevator if he doesn't decide to kill
you instead but it's on the Internet
that people feel free to be themselves
which is why I don't like this
delineation sometimes between oh thats
that's just how people are on the
internet that's not how they are in real
life
well no but those are real people on the
internet right these are actual human
beings who are expressing their points
of view on the internet it's just the
Internet is just a mode of communication
that's all so no I mean if you discover
that a sizable portion of the people you
encounter online are just absolute
maniacs and scumbags unfortunately that
means that they're just are a lot of
maniacs and scumbags in the world
because almost everybody is online and
this is where people let their true
colors shine because they feel like they
have the the ability to do that without
shame or without fear of reprisal or
whatever so that's the first thing the
other point is that while this woman is
obviously over the top she is
representative of a group and not a very
small group either who are just I mean I
I don't I don't know what else you
call them besides dog worshipers I mean
they really there are it seems like
there are a lot of people in this
country who really do worship dogs they
actually think that dogs are like gods
basically and I don't even think that
that's hyperbole I think that that's
really the case now I have no problem
with people who love pets and love
animals in general I think that's great
I have a dog myself I like my dog but
he's just a dog as I said my feelings
towards him do not even get close to the
ball part of my feelings for my kids
like they're not even in the ball park
next door
they're like on a ball park on another
planet somewhere just not even in this
just not anywhere in the vicinity right
as in if we were all starving to death
and we had no other food I would in a
second kill my dog and feed him to my
kids right I wouldn't have to think
about it that's just that's no problem
that's where he ranks in the hierarchy
but it's fine I like having him around
and he's a dog and it's fine but there
are people and this woman is a member of
this group obviously who really do love
animals more than they love people who
love their pets even more than they love
their own children and that's the really
disturbing thing that people at a
minimum they consider their pets to be
on an equal playing field with their own
with their human children and these
kinds of people exist and I believe
based on my observations that it is a
growing group and it's a problem because
it's sort of a sign of a dying
civilization when everyone starts to
worship animals like we're we're
reverting back to paganism all I want to
say to this group it if you're in this
group of people all I want to say to you
is this and I'm not talking again I'm
not talking about people who love their
pets that's fine if you love your pets
more than you love people and even more
or equal to how you love your children
well so what I would say is it's not
okay to be how you are it's it's not
okay to like animals more than people it
really isn't that's actually a very
demented and disturb
point of view and it stems entirely and
this is why it's so such a problem it
stems entirely from your selfishness so
the reason you love animals more than
people is because your relationship with
your dog is all about you right and
that's what people like about dogs they
your dog is obsessed with you follows
you around fawns all over you literally
slobbering all over you thinks of
nothing but you while you're out of the
house he just wants you to come back and
when your back is so excited and and
that's why people like dogs but human
beings aren't like that right people
aren't going to live every second of
every day thinking only of you pining
after you wanting to be with you I don't
know I mean personally I wouldn't want
that kind of attachment from another
human being it's just it's a little too
much like I need a little bit of space
but people have their own internal life
in their own existence that is not all
about you their own identity and I think
for the people who like dogs more the
people that's why you don't like people
as much because you've yet to meet a
person who will structure their entire
existence around you and you don't like
that because you are a complete
egomaniac so much of an egomaniac that
as far as you're concerned the hierarchy
of beings is it's like you at number one
and then dogs and then all other people
that's a problem that's all I'm saying
alright let's go to emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com all right let's see here yeah
maybe I'll save that one for tomorrow
okay no I will I'll read this alright so
over the last week or so we've been
having this debate on the show about
whether or not we should use the Bible
when debating with unbelievers atheists
secular people about issues that are not
explicitly theological and one example
we've been using is abortion like if
you're debating if you're trying to
persuade a you know a non-christian
person about the evils of a bore
do you throw the Bible at them or do you
use science logic reason and those sorts
of things and I have been arguing that
no you don't throw the Bible you use
science logic and reason well I gave to
make my point I gave as an example and
because it just so happened that a
couple weeks ago I was speaking at
Boston University and a woman stood up
during the Q&A and said that that in
fact she had been convinced persuaded
over to the pro-life side by the
arguments presented by me and and ben
shapiro and other people the daily wire
and other conservatives so here's an
example and the reason i brought her up
is because the the people on the
bible-thumping side of it what they like
to claim is that well you're never gonna
persuade someone with logic and science
it's never gonna happen you need to just
you need to just quote the Bible to them
and let that work in their heart that's
the only way it's the only thing that
can work you're never gonna persuade
someone just with just with arguments
well I said no actually you can it
happens all the time actually it's very
possible to do here's one example
and that woman happened to write an
email sort of giving more context about
her own personal journey and so I
thought it'd be really interesting to
read this email especially for people
who say that this is not possible that
you can't do this well you can do it and
let me read the email to you she says I
saw your tweet yesterday where you
mentioned when I stood up and spoke at
your BU speech and I've been listening
and reading the debates you've been
having about how to go about discussing
abortion with people and would like to
give you my two cents like I said that
night earlier in my life the nineties I
was a lefty and social worker
specifically for the parenting and
pregnant teen programs that popped up
after Clinton's welfare reform went
through
I watched teenage girls get abortions
depending on who the father was
I also had an 18 year old with two kids
who got an abortion every other time
after really working for the government
child social services for five years
9/11 and my older brothers having
children all happening around the same
time like a perfect storm my views
completely changed and now I am very
much a libertarian conservative and I
see how dumb I was and see myself in all
of these college kids who are who
at york uae's it's embarrassing but
being a libertarian I was still
pro-choice a government shouldn't be
involved right anyway I remember the
first time in the last couple of years
that I started to actually think about
my position the first thing that ever
gave me pause I was technically
pro-choice but never felt it would be my
choice you know that whole argument in
my life no one ever gave logical
arguments from the other side until
Trump was elected no one on the right
talked about this stuff out loud or
confidently especially during the
previous eight years and during the 2016
election and after I got turned on to
the Daily wire and steven crowder the
first thing that ever got me to really
think about it was when one of you said
so enslaved Dave's so enslaved days
would you have just said I would never
own a slave but I wouldn't tell other
people not to that's when I told that's
when I would say my ears perked up for
the first time and I was open to
listening the next thing that hit me was
when one of you said if it's just a
clump of cells if it's really not a baby
and there's really nothing wrong with it
why is it always talked about being such
a difficult decision why are women
agonizing and feeling ashamed
I'd always found the whole rape and
incest exception thing inconsistent it's
either murdering a baby or it's not my
thing was that I knew at a certain point
it was not okay but wasn't sure that
wasn't sure what that point was and did
give him much thought then I saw that
shot chart that steven crowder uses and
I think Ben uses it too and you see at
each point what it looks like and it's
it's hard to argue at any point that it
doesn't at least look like a baby
even the tiniest of embryos under a
microscope and I heard one one of you
say does the vaginal canal have some
magic power that instills life as a baby
passes through it but I was still
wavering until DNA and fingerprints one
of you said that they have their own
unique DNA almost immediately the last
argument that hung on is always it's
part of the woman's body etc but to know
that it has its own unique DNA and soon
after it's fingerprints means it's a
separate entity unto itself
it is separate from the mother even
though it's connected so I knew
immediately how I felt and I turned my
husband and I would say that say to each
other quietly that we knew we had we had
changed how we felt since becoming aware
of the daily wire and steven crowder but
that's how he said it like when we were
voting we knew we were voting for Trump
but we never said that
words out loud but not until the night
at bu I did say it out loud and I can
tell you exactly why there were two
things you said number one the whole
relive your life backwards thing
from today reverse it back 10 years 20
years to your birth and then about 60
seconds before your birth was that not
still you
she was quoting me there paraphrasing
number two everything is alive dead or
inanimate so another argument I made I
realized that that I realized that night
plants are alive and they don't have a
heartbeat never thought about that and I
still have a little trouble like the
planet is that alive is the Sun alive is
rain alive on the way home I used my
husband I asked my husband like my
kidney inside my body is that alive and
he said yes
and I said I'm not sure about that what
about what about my kidney by itself on
a table outside my body and he said
that's dead flesh that made sense but
the main point of my email I was raised
by a non-practicing Catholic mother and
a rabid anti religious atheist father
who both good people she says in
parenthesis who took me under his wing
and was always in my ear I turned out
for most of my life a hardcore atheist
even though I went through the
sacraments I did so to prove a point
that I was beating the system because I
didn't believe and I could get married
in a church I had always thought to
believe in religion was weak and shows
you are not intelligent until I was
married with a child who we are raising
in the Catholic Church due to my husband
and I am seeing that spark I missed out
on the sense of purpose and being I
don't know if the whole god thing is
true but there is something I definitely
missed out on feeling about myself and
not believing it as a child if that
makes sense and I wanted to back up your
argument I heard you make on your
podcast after you mentioned me standing
up the other night you said if you can
get people to believe you about
something like this logically they may
then wonder if you're right about other
things too and that's what's happening
to me now listening to all of you crazy
smart people being right about all these
things and making complete sense I'm
much more open to religion than ever
before and the more I read Ben's new
book and listening to you and hearing so
many explanations to questions I always
had when thinking how can some smart
people believe this so yes I was
converted on abortion by science and now
realizing you guys are so smart my ears
have perked up in just the same way
about religion and who knows where that
goes
thank you and then she doesn't want me
to give her name
okay so I wanted to read that whole
thing because I think that that's first
of all I mean it proves a point and this
isn't a point about me like oh look at
this one you know she talked a lot more
about other conservative steven crowder
and ben shapiro so it's not just like
arguments that I presented but so that's
not the point the point it's two things
here number one it is possible okay and
she's not the only one who has been
convinced persuaded by logical and
scientific arguments not just on
abortion but on so many other issues and
not just by me or ben shapiro steven
crowder but by anybody right
it is possible so this is for all the
emails I've gotten saying it's not
possible you can't do it okay well what
about this woman is she do you think
she's the one exception in the whole
universe or do you think maybe you're
wrong maybe it is possible and the
second point here is well I think what
you've seen this email why I wanted to
read it is it's a testament to this
person who sent the email that this is
someone who is has intellectual
integrity right who's willing to admit
that they might be wrong and that's all
you really need like if you're talking
to something if you're if you're arguing
with someone who doesn't have
intellectual integrity who's not
intellectually curious who doesn't have
any sort of moral fortitude or courage
well in in that moment there's probably
nothing you could say to persuade them
you could you could probably plant some
seeds in their mind that may sprout
later on but in that moment there's
nothing you can do because they have to
be willing to receive but if you're
talking to somebody who is it even if
they disagree with you via mentally but
if they have intellectual integrity and
they're at least willing to listen and
they're open to hearing the other side
if you're talking to someone like that
well you could change their whole way of
thinking in 20 minutes you could
theoretically
and that's why I think it's so important
and you're never really gonna know in
the moment
whether you're talk to us someone with
intellectual integrity or not so you're
not really gonna know that but if you
are and you've got someone who's who's
open-minded and they're listening to you
the last thing you want to do is say
something that's going to cause them to
close their mind off to you because you
just had this amazing opportunity to
convince someone of something and if you
if you go the wrong route they're gonna
close it off and you're gonna miss that
opportunity and I think as I've been
saying and as I've been arguing if
you're if you have someone like this who
you're talking to
if you go the bible-thumping route you
lost the opportunity they're gonna close
you out because they've heard all that
stuff before they don't want to be
preached at there's there's a lot of
baggage there they don't everything I'm
not gonna repeat it all but they don't
agree with the premise and all of that
all you've succeeded is they've closed
you off they're walking away you failed
you just fail if you can keep that
Avenue open just keep the door open
which I think requires a little bit of
you know prudence and and and trying to
meet them on their level if you can do
that then then anything is possible so I
think I think that's great I really
enjoyed that email and again the credit
goes not to me or ben shapiro or steven
crowder or anyone else who presented an
argument or because the arguments were
making are just super obvious most of
the people listening you all could make
those arguments yourselves it's just
that she grew up in an environment where
she had never been exposed to that way
of thinking and if you're not exposed to
it then you know then you need to be
exposed to it first before you can start
thinking that way so the credit goes to
her for being open to that and and at
least willing to listen which most
people unfortunately are not all right
let's see this is from Michael says dear
Matt and a Baptist Church and I'm
frequently treated to sermons on the
evils of alcohol however in my personal
study
every time the Bible addresses
consumption of alcohol it specifically
refers to wine when I asked my pastor
about this he told me that wine is just
the biblical shorthand for all alcohol
beverages I am curious if this is the
case or of wine is specifically
mentioned due to its sacramental nature
would love to get the Catholic
perspective as well as your personal
convictions on the subject I think I've
talked about the alcohol thing before on
the show I'm not sure so I don't repeat
myself too much any more than I already
have
but yeah the idea that the Bible
condemns alcohol outright is
theologically absurd that's that is just
a theological invention I'm afraid to
say on the part of your pastor and any
other pastor it gets up there and says
all all all alcohol is evil what they're
doing is that's a personal belief that
they have which is fine you know you're
you're entitled to that personal belief
and it's perfectly fine it's perfectly
fine to have that personal belief and
that personal conviction that alcohol is
you know that you don't want to drink
alcohol great I have no problem with
that but when you try to take that
personal conviction and impose it on to
the text to try to make it into more
than just your personal conviction to
try to turn it into God's conviction
then I have a problem with that and not
because no matter what the subject is I
don't care if it's alcohol or anything
else I have a problem with doing that
and I think it's wrong and honestly it's
it's dishonest because there's just no
I'm sorry Jesus Christ's first miracle
recorded in the Gospel as far as we know
his first miracle on earth was providing
wine for a wedding and if you try to
tell me that it was it was uh it was
non-alcoholic wine that he was providing
to a wedding I mean that is just so
ridiculous there's no textual reason for
that at all you know you're not getting
that from the text you're getting it
from your own head I'm by the way I'm
not yelling at you Michael because
you're asking the question I'm just
yelling at everyone who makes this claim
which isn't you it's completely
ridiculous in fact it even says that the
the guests at the at the at the party at
the wedding were shocked that it was it
was this was
finest mine it was the best wine and
they were shocked that that had been
saved for for the end ok do you think
that the non-alcoholic wine that grape
juice is the finest wine the best wine
no and why is it that typically and this
is a practice even still today why is it
that the that the usually the the lower
quality alcohol is provided at the end
well because by then people have been
drinking and they're feeling good
they're feeling loose and they're gonna
be less discerning about the alcohol you
give them it's the same thing I have a
Christmas party every year at my house
my wife and I do and we stock the fridge
with beer and we've got the good
expensive beer but we don't I don't want
to pay to stock the entire fridge with
good expensive beer so it got some good
expensive craft beer and then we also
get like some jingling or Coors Light or
something at the end of the night all
that's left is the cores or the jingling
and then people start drinking that
because now they're they're a little bit
less discerning about it so ok that is
clearly means that this is alcoholic
wine we're talking about at a party okay
you're not gonna have it's not a big
emergency if you run out of grape juice
at a wedding if you run out of wine
that's a problem right because it's it's
hard to have a fun party without any
alcohol so Jesus Christ first miracle on
earth is to provide alkyl alkyl halt to
a party and yet these people think that
they can make some sort of argument that
the Bible condemns alcohol outright it's
yeah again it's fine if you don't like
it just stop pretend I'm trying to put
that on the text just admit that this is
your personal opinion and that's fine
it's just annoys man all right let's do
one more here Oh
speaking about
here we go this is from Joe it says
brother Matt I believe you're mostly a
bourbon man but I'm curious if you fancy
any fancy any rise or scotches or other
whiskey's please rank your top five
whiskey's have a blessed holy week I
could drink a rye or Scotch but I'm not
you know I basically stick with Bourbons
myself although if I'm at someone's
house and they you know crack open a
bottle scotch
believe me I'll have some so my top five
I won't rank them in order so this is
not an order but these are my go-to sob
for Roses Woodford Knob Creek Blanton's
and I guess makers 46 will be mine
probably for Four Roses is uh you know
it's not the highest quality of all
Bourbons by any means but it's just a
really good go-to relatively inexpensive
and it's great stuff alright we will
leave it there on that wonderful note
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed today on the bench
Shapiro show Democrats claim that
criticism of Aloha no Mar is incitement
sure becomes a Republican and Senator
Cory Booker reveals a secret about
sanctuary cities this is the Ben Shapiro
show